[ RAP MUSIC PLAYS ]
♪ SUPPORT THE POLICE ♪
♪ OH ♪
♪ PEOPLE FLIP US THE BIRD,
ALWAYS DISRESPECTED ♪
♪ I'M JUST DOIN' MY JOB,
SERVIN' AND PROTECTIN' ♪
♪ WALKIN' THE BEAT,
MY BADGE IS MY BLING-BLING ♪
♪ ROB MY STREET, I'LL SEND
YOUR ASS TO SING-SING ♪
♪ ROLLIN' IN THE ROLLER,
CRUISIN' IN THE CRUISER ♪
♪ I'M "A" NUMBER ONE
AND YOU'S A 3-TIME LOSER ♪
♪ ...AND $40 FINE ♪
♪ I PUT THE "COP"
IN "COP A FEEL" ♪
♪ STEP OUT OF LINE,
YOUR ASS IS MINE ♪
♪ TELL THE JUDGE,
'CAUSE YOU GOT NO APPEAL ♪
♪ HO'S IN THE BACKSEAT,
I'M RIDIN' SHOTGUN ♪
♪ YOU WANT MY DIGITS? ♪
♪ CALL 9-1-1 ♪
♪ I'M THE MAN IN RENO ♪
♪ THE POLICE, THE 5-0, A C-O-P
IN THE COUNTY OF WASHOE ♪
♪ COUNT ON MY PROTECTION
ON COMIN' THROUGH ♪
♪ DON'T DISRESPECT ME
AND I WON'T SHOOT YOU ♪
♪ YOU DOWN WITH C-O-P? ♪
♪ RENO S.D. ♪
♪ SO, PUNK THE POLICE ♪
♪ PEACE ♪